even in a place where there used to
wildfires this has taken them by
surprise a fire that started at dawn by
mid-morning had spread across 6,000
acres and so far continues to defy all
efforts to contain it as the flames
crept closer to residential areas the
people who live here and students at a
college in the path of the fire were
ordered to leave the flames engulfing
farm buildings and camper vans the fire
in the hills and canyons north of malibu
is being driven by record-breaking high
temperatures and strong Santa Ana winds
bringing 50 mile-per-hour gusts of warm
air to ground already suffering from a
dry winter those who weren't told to
leave did all they could to protect
their homes I want to save my home and
invest a lot in this house and a lot of
time and memories and I go don't want to
lose it so I'm here until the end
whatever it takes the fire has started
to impact traffic as well at least one
stretch of freeway was closed as the
flames surge towards the Pacific coast
and even as they try to bring this under
control firefighters elsewhere in
California for having to deal with at
least half a dozen smaller bushfires so
I can get these flames back down again I
had them down for a while they do have a
well-rehearsed plan for fires like this
but they know they're dealing with an
unpredictable force of nature
wildfire season has come early to
California and a long hot summer lies
ahead right out Greg Milam Sky News Los
Angeles